the man who is known for the tales yes
own told children young and almost
full-grown ones like hat Danza hat one
horton hears a who and the Grinch who
stole Christmas got a new heart too he
was a doctor named Zeus but not a doctor
at all just a man who loved writing for
both big and small on today is my
graphics we offer the story of Ted
Geisel the American author Theodor Seuss
Geisel was born in 1904 to German
immigrants his father owns a very
successful brewery in Springfield
Massachusetts as a child his favorite
pastime was to go to the zoo with his
family every single Sunday he was so
good at drawing animals that his father
bought him a sketchbook that he added to
every weekend and his mom allowed him to
paint on the walls of his bedroom his
animals always looks like caricatures
and from a young age his parents could
tell that he had a very whimsical
imagination after prohibition in the
1920s his father could no longer run the
brewery and actually chose to become the
head of the Springfield zoo instead Ted
Geisel could now go to the zoo and
sketch the animals as often as he wanted
and he continued to do this for the rest
of his life
growing up during World War one many
children in school would make fun of gas
or calling their family drunken Germans
this stereotype only intensified during
Prohibition since their family's
livelihood came from making beer this
isolated him from his peers a lot and he
spends a lot of time alone and he was
largely an introvert with the close
friends he did have he would use this
good sense of humor to cope with the bad
times he was accepted to Dartmouth
College and he started drawing short
comics for their humor magazine in his
senior year Geisel became the editor and
this was the beginning of a lifelong
literary career one night the Dean Court
guys all drinking an illegal bottle of
bootleg gin and having a party in his
dorm so he was removed from his position
as editor he decided to secretly
continue contributing to the magazine
and went by the pen name dr. Seuss Seuss
was his mother's maiden name and when he
was born his parents made it his middle
name
it's actually pronounced voice which I'm
sure some commenter has commented in
below before getting to this point in
the video but everyone always got it
wrong when reading it with an American
accent so he just decided to let people
call him Seuss even though he did not
have a doctoral degree he decided to go
by doctor instead of mister because his
father had always hoped that his love of
animals would have taken him to be a vet
but instead he chose to be an artist and
a writer instead after graduating from
Dartmouth he moved to England to attend
graduate school at the University of
Oxford he planned to become a professor
but ended up leaving after just one
semester to move to New York City he was
writing funny ads and illustrating them
with characters and he was able to
publish his first cartoon in The
Saturday Evening Post in 1927 in the
beginning Ted Geisel
fully intended to write jokes for adults
but his ad contract forbid him from
publishing any comics in the funny
papers because his clients felt that it
would be in direct competition
however the contract never mentions
children's books which is why he decided
to get started in now genre he wrote his
first children's book and to think I saw
it on Mulberry Street but every
publisher rejected him the story is
about a young boy he uses his
imagination to elaborate over-the-top
details about where he lives which is
something that guys always did as a
child but licious saw this as
encouraging children to Lions they
thought it would set a bad example at
the time children's books were only
meant to teach kids moral lessons about
manners and obeying their parents they
were not exactly enjoyable to read and
there were very strict rules about what
could not or could be in them guys will
continue to draw ads in New York but he
eventually ran into one of his old
friends from Dartmouth Eve just so
happened to have gotten a job at
Vanguard Press his friends helps get
Mulberry Street published the book only
sought modest success but it was still
enough to get his foot in the door of
the industry the dr. Seuss books
continued to feature stories where
children were getting into some kind of
trouble his stories they were fun and
much more than just a thinly veiled
lecture now he did after adjust and
write to the market though and in 1940
dr. Cu switched over to Random House and
he published a book called Horton
hatches the egg which gives a moral
lesson for children about loyalty and
keeping promises this book became far
more successful than any of his previous
titles but on the brink of America's
involvement in world
- you guys'll was about to take a very
long break from writing children's
stories for a long time guys'll stop
sketching pictures of whimsical
creatures and began drawing Hitler
instead what he felt that political
cartoons were so important that he
started working for a liberal newspaper
called p.m. which published his
political commentary for years the
United States refused to get involved
with the war in Geisel strongly believed
that the country needed to help the
people suffering in Europe he finally
got his wish though because the United
States entered World War two in December
of 1941 Geisel wanted to join and serve
in the army but he was already in his
late 30s which was farty Walt
however he enlisted anyway and says
after looking over his resume the army
recruiter made him into one of the
propaganda playwrights and he earns the
title of captain Geisel they moved Ted
Geisel and his wife out to Los Angeles
and put him in charge of the animation
unit this is where they worked on
propaganda cartoons for the US Army
called private snafu which were very
popular among the new army recruits dr.
Seuss wasn't the Muny famous names have
come out of the Army playwrights though
Chuck Jones was the director of Looney
Tunes and he directed the cartoon series
Stan Lee of Marvel Comics was also one
of the playwrights Ted Geisel wrote and
directed several propaganda films
including ones that were called your job
in Germany and your job in Japan at the
time he was being criticized for being
too sympathetic towards the enemy
countries that after the war was over in
1945 these movies were edited into a
feature-length documentary called
designed for death which eventually won
an Academy Award in 1947 he took
advantage of this public recognition by
publishing another children's book
called mecha Ella got spool which was
his first book in seven years
in 1950 ghazal wrote an animated short
story called gerald mcboing boing and it
won the Academy Award for Best Animated
Film after winning these two Oscars he
did what most people do in Hollywood
which was write a full-length screenplay
called
the five thousand fingers of dr. T in
1953 the movie is a live-action musical
about a young boy whose piano teacher is
an evil villain bent on kidnapping
children and forcing them to play his
giant piano forever in the first draft
of the movie the entire
story played out very much like his
books he also wrote songs that made the
movie fast-paced and exciting but
everything went downhill when the
Hollywood executives pushed back saying
that the movie needed an adult love
interest and jokes written for the
benefit of parents therefore they cut
half of his songs and hired a second
screenwriter the revisions ruined the
story and it flopped in the box-office
if you watch the movie it's easy to spot
the very funny and crazy moments written
by dr. Seuss mixed with the traditional
Hollywood drama that made the movie drag
on forever today five thousand fingers
has become a cult classic because it's
so terrible that it's actually kind of
good Ted Geisel said that it was the
biggest failure of his career and that
he would never trust executives to make
another movie again after taking a long
break from writing new books Ted Geisel
learns that children's literacy rates in
the United States were dramatically low
so he decided that he was gonna do
something about that this is when he
wrote The Cat in the Hat and it was
published in 1957 when he was 53 years
old he purposefully wrote the book with
a very simple 225 word vocabulary to
ensure that nearly every elementary
school child was able to read it this
book exploded in popularity and it truly
did help increase children's literacy
rates by 1960 it sold over a million
copies and parents worth now searching
for more dr. Seuss books that had been
published in the past one of guys those
friends gave him the challenge of
reducing the vocabulary down to a mere
50 words since he accepted this is when
he wrote green eggs and ham which was
equally as successful as the Cat in the
Hat
he proved that writing doesn't have to
be about showing off a big vocabulary
the important thing is to tell a good
story and he was a genius at doing just
that guys are beginning head of
children's literature at Random House
and edited his own books as well as
contributing to the popular berenstain
bears series now the guys who was in
charge he made the new goal of Random
House's children's book department to
make the stories as simple as possible
so that children would understand every
word and enjoy reading the book instead
of struggling this way it would improve
children's literacy because they would
feel good about the experience and
reading more books a lot of famous
authors wanted to be a part of this
project including Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory author Roald Dahl and
even Breakfast at Tiffany's author
Truman Capote they both tried to pitch
manuscripts to ISIL but even though they
were both amazing writers in their own
right their children's books they were
rejected for not fully understanding the
simplicity that geyser was looking for
guys all started working seven days a
week writing and illustrating and
published at least one new dr. Seuss
book every single year the story seems
simple but he once said that he wrote
over a thousand pages before he could
narrow the story down to just 60 over
the course of his lifetime he authored
and co-authored 66 books
throughout his life Ted Geisel got to
enjoy the success of having a superstar
pen name without the annoying and
invasive parts of being a celebrity even
though his picture was in newspapers
across the country and he received over
a thousand fan letters a day very few
children actually knew what the real dr.
Seuss looked like so he could still
blend into society without drawing a lot
of attention to himself a cocktail
parties in New York and Los Angeles
Ted was worried that people would expect
a lot of him so he would tell elaborate
stories but only speak to one or two
people before retreating into another
room to read smoke or have a quiet
conversation even though it was quiet he
was always playing jokes whenever an
adult asked for his autograph he would
write a long and elaborate fake name in
the book and hand it back to them he was
an introvert so socializing wore him out
in general and he was always afraid that
his true self Ted Geisel was an
incredibly boring person compared to the
whimsical persona of dr. Seuss on the
contrary friends said that they believed
that the select few people he chose to
speak to were incredibly lucky and
everyone thought he was very interesting
he just didn't believe in himself you
would think that for a man who wrote
children's books II would have loved
being around kids but the truth is that
he often felt uncomfortable around
children and said that they're just like
socializing with adults I'm a great
while others can be real jerks and he
could only handle it for short periods
of time but he had to learn to cope
especially when stories like The Cat in
the Hat became popular and his agents
encouraged him to go on a book tour once
I'm at a shopping mall he slipped away
from a crowd of children and started
playing pranks on mall employees by
altering the displays his agents
actually caught him changing the prices
of designer shoes to make them less
expensive Ted did not want to disappoint
the kids though because he knew that
when children imagined dr. Seuss they
expected to see someone out of Whoville
but he was just a normal guy after a few
awkward speeches at elementary schools
he decided to stop being himself and act
like dr. Seuss he started speaking in
sing-songy rhymes that he wrote ahead of
time and thought of clever answers to
frequently asked questions offeree
started essentially playing a character
he felt far more comfortable even though
dr. Seuss wrote children's stories that
were loved around the world his personal
life was
far more complicated the story of the
woman he fell in love with became one of
the main scandals of his life that's in
order to tell the whole story we need to
go all the way back in time to his
college years while he was a students at
Oxford Ted Geisel met a fellow American
English major named Helen Palmer she was
five years older than he was and always
ready to graduate with a master's degree
she's that behind Ted in class and when
she saw his sketches of animals she
encouraged him to become an artist
instead of a professor he dropped out
after spending just one semester in
Oxford but Helen went on to graduate
they got married soon after and moved to
New York City together she would
eventually go on to publish several
children's books of her own for the
majority of their marriage Helen and Ted
had a very happy relationship and they
were very supportive of one another's
works as a young girl Helen survived
having polio because of her poor health
she was not able to have children of her
own
however they enjoyed the freedom of not
having children he and Helen travelled
to 30 different countries together their
own zones have purchased their dream
home in San Diego California and they
even had a watch tower on top of a
mountain Helen would edit his work
giving feedback and also taking care of
the household while Ted worked in his
office for a long time their marriage it
was pretty perfect
in 1954 just a year after his Hollywood
movie flopped Helen was diagnosed with
guillain barre syndrome which is an
incredibly painful condition where the
body's immune system attacks its own
nerves
she became completely paralyzed and was
placed inside of an iron lung if she
were to leave this huge metal container
Helen wouldn't have been able to breathe
on her own for a while they thought that
she might die Ted Geisel stopped writing
in illustrating completely giving up
everything in his life to be by her side
even today there is still no cure for
Yan Barre syndrome helen has to go
through intensive therapy to learn to
walk and talk again but she continued to
be very sick without much recovery time
in between to make matters worse she was
eventually diagnosed with terminal
cancer like anyone who's feeling ill
Helen was no longer acting like a usual
self they started sleeping in separate
bedrooms in their relationship became
more of a friendship Ted went on to have
a secret affair with a married woman
named Audrey Demond who was neighbors
and friends with the couple even though
he had fallen in love with someone else
he never left his wife but when Helen
was 69 years old she found out about the
fair and she couldn't handle the
possibility that he may leave her she
felt that she was far too old and ill to
start her life over and try to move on
with someone else in 1967 she killed
herself leaving a suicide note that was
just as lyrical as their children's
books Helen died of a drug overdose and
Ted was completely beside himself with
guilt and grief he blames himself for
her death and said I didn't know whether
to kill myself
burn the house down or just go away and
get lost
Audrey stoned Demond divorced her
husband and they got married that
following year Audrey was 18 years
younger than Gasol and she had two
daughters who were 9 and 14 at that time
she sent them to boarding school because
she knew that they were unhappy about
the divorce the entire community judged
Audrey and Ted harshly and they were
shunned by many of their friends and
neighbors because they blamed them for
Helens death Audrey and Ted they stayed
together until his death and he credited
her with helping him find his love for
writing again and having a chance at a
second life for the first time he got to
experience being a stepfather and a
grandfather
he wrote sometimes when I see my
granddaughter's make small discoveries
of their own I wish I were a child
[Music]
in 1984 Ted Geisel won the Pulitzer
Prize in children's literature and his
stories were translated into 30
languages dr. Seuss is now considered to
be a classic author who is thoughts to
each new generation and his books
continued to be reprinted today Theodor
Geisel was diagnosed with mouth cancer
from years of smoking and he died in
1991 at the age of 87 three weeks before
his death he asked for a bed to be moved
into his office so that he could be
surrounded by the sketches and
sculptures of his characters and have a
view of the mountains from his picture
window when he was alive Ted Geisel did
not want any merchandise or movies to be
made for his books
however after he died his wife Audrey
became in charge of the Seuss brands she
chose to allow licensing to make toys
games and Hollywood films so long as she
was there to oversee the creative
direction and make sure that it would
have been up to Ted standards some
people have criticized her saying that
it's exploitation but she believes that
in today's ever-changing world of
children's media the dr. Seuss stories
may have not lasted as long as they have
if they didn't get a modern makeover
Audrey she was right and her decisions
have helped keep his legacy alive
he appeared on the 2018 Forbes list of
richest dead celebrities his book sold
4.8 million copies and and 16 million
dollars in 2017 alone his estate is
currently worth around 75 million
dollars she gives a huge portion of the
proceeds from our husband's royalties to
the dr. Seuss Foundation which is a
nonprofit organization that donates
money to various causes so all of the
money from those new dr. Seuss movie
remakes up actually going to pay for
college scholarships libraries school
art programs
and cancer research surely dead guy salt
would be happy to know that even years
after his death his stories are still
making a difference with children
everywhere so I really hope you found
that video interesting if you did please
do give us a thumbs up below and don't
forget to subscribe also I've got
another channel it's called top tens
we've got top 10 lists we look at all
sorts of different fun facts and things
like that it's a daily show so you can
go check that up and subscribe if you
want to you'll find a link on the screen
now as well as below and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]